you
hey everybody its charlie new flash
costume so let's go crazy about this you
may have noticed a little while ago
Grant Gustin said it's about time Barry
gets a new costume just teasing the idea
that he would get some new version of
his flash costume you've actually
already seen him in a bunch of different
versions of the costume since the show
started so I'll explain what's going on
with this all the coolest versions of
the costume from the TV show in the
comics in the stuff that they might be
able to do in the future
just one in a long line of really
awesome Super Bowl weekend trailers and
teasers that are dropping I'm doing a
new round of the flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment about the
flash on this video be sure to click
that Bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss anything
so what's going on the actor who played
wally west was teasing that he was
getting a new costume a while ago so
every season even within each season
they tweak the costume just a little bit
even if you can't visibly tell there's
actually a couple different versions
that he wears depending on the types of
scenes as they film there's one version
he wears when the mask is fully on is a
harder version so it doesn't move around
when he turns his head but then when
he's filming other scenes with the cowl
off when he's just walking around with
it pulled off it's a different version
that's a little bit softer that sort of
folds on itself the hard version is
almost like a leather helmet but since
season 1 there's been a couple different
versions of Barry's costume so far the
first version was in the pilot it was
this really hard costume
it gave Grant Gustin these crazy
headaches so they had to make a better
version of the first version of the suit
so hourly it looked the same but it was
a lot more modular there were different
pieces in all ways he actually saw this
picture of him from behind the scenes he
always doesn't wear the emblem until he
walks on set a lot of people saw this
and because of the eddy episode they're
like oh maybe it's going to be a
flashback it'll be the old version of
the emblem but even if that's true he
still walks around when he's in his
flash costume without the emblem on they
don't attach it till they get ready to
do scenes because he zips the suit up
the front it's almost like a jacket now
so over the course of season 1 and
season 2 the suit itself has gotten a
lot more comfortable for him to wear
when it came time to make Wally's suit
they kind of did the same thing so I'm
guessing the suit that we saw him in at
the beginning of the season the Wally
suit is actually changing just to get a
little more comfortable you see that
Wally has a slightly different haircut
in the behind-the-scenes pictures so I
think it'll look a little bit cooler but
you won't be able to tell the difference
unless you're really paying attention
closely it's the same basic suit the
biggest color change was at the end of
last season one got over when I fought
over slash at Christmas he said that
we'd be fighting for centuries wait you
can't really think that this is from the
future
I would mean dr. wells whoever he is is
also from the future
I have to say I'm really digging the
brighter red suit and the white on the
symbol
I felt wait a second suppose we now
change the color on your suit will it be
because we got the idea from this
picture that would mean we're living in
a causal Nexus wow this is so trippy
like Marty and the Polaroid trippy Cisco
asked the burning question do we make
that white emblem because we saw it in
the future or were we always destined to
make it come to season two they actually
make the white emblem and then they
start making upgrades to the actual tech
of the suit he fights captain cold they
have a version of the emblem that will
heat up so Cisco tweaks that technology
based on the types of bosses that Barry
goes up again so there's been all kinds
of teasers about future versions of the
costume there have been many different
versions in the comics so the idea is is
that we'll eventually see a future
version of Barry in a crazier more
hardcore version of the suit now I'm not
talking about flash movies suit like the
injustice looking version of the suit
I'm talking about a Barry that's more
full of speed force maybe the blue
version of the costume or something
close to it just to let us know that he
has become this crazy being so we might
not actually get to see that this season
but we might get teasers for it later on
I'm not expecting him to wear anything
but the red version of the costume on
most of the show the closest WTF color
change that I actually think that we'll
see this season is a future vision of
Wally wearing the red costume in a time
Berry has died and gone away and he's
become the main version of the flash I
think on one of the TV shows we'll see a
future vision of that but on the main
show it will always be Barry and Wally
in their respective costumes so just
remember that Grant Gustin is the main
actor on the flash they're not going to
kill him off he's not going to go away
he'll still be there they signed
seven-year contracts but there might be
episodes when he gets stuck somewhere
and Wally has to step up the gorilla
City episode is coming there'll be a
really cool
Wally iris team-up while everybody else
is dealing with the gorilla city stuff
that's the kind of stuff I'm talking
about the new version of the cows that
he's having made right here is probably
just a more hardcore version of his red
costume so in the comics you may have
seen the blue costume that belongs to
the new 52 future version of Barry Allen
from 20 years in the future from this
post-apocalyptic timeline where all this
craziness has happened Wally has died he
hasn't been able to save all the ones
that he's loved and he blames himself
for creating all these cracks in the
Speed Force so the only solution he can
come up with is to go back and kill
himself in the past so the new 52 flash
costume looked a little bit different a
little bit shinier I wasn't a big fan of
it the blue costume was really cool
though it was another blue costume
during the war of light that Barry wore
when he was a blue lantern that was a
more cloth looking version slightly less
hardcore but still very cool because he
had the Lantern ring that's something
that we can dream about but to probably
never be able to do on the TV shows the
war of light where everybody gets
Lantern rings the most hardcore version
of the flash costume that we could ever
possibly see is the god of death
speedster so Barry Allen during Darkseid
war in the comics gets merged with the
black racer by the anti-monitor
and he becomes the new god of death so
it drives him a little mad Batman became
the god of knowledge sitting on the
Mobius chair they all went a little nuts
all the Justice League members went a
little crazy the fun thing about that is
the TV show can always play with ideas
like that likes Avatar almost looks like
a version of that flash just this crazy
god of speed god of death but one of the
reasons why I think that the flash TV
show won't actually
Berry in one of those costumes is mostly
because it's a little too crazy for
people that don't read comics and just
tune in week to week without really
understanding what's happening so if he
showed up one day in the god of death
costume people would be like I don't
understand what's happening
where's the flash the flash is in a red
costume which I know it sounds
infuriating because if you read comics
you want to see the really cool comic
book stuff so they always try to find
really fun ways to make those Easter
eggs or show you visions of that in the
future but then at the end of the day
take things back to normal so that when
they show up in the next episode
everybody's back to square one so
whatever ends up happening at the end of
this season when we pick up next season
there'll be slightly different versions
of the costume physically they'll be a
little more comfortable but they'll
still be the yellow and red costume in
the other like smaller reasons for them
making a bunch of different versions of
the costume during the season is because
they trash a lot of them so every once
in a while they do have to make a new
one but let me know what is your
favorite version of the flash costume in
which one do you hope makes it onto the
show I know everybody wants to see a
version of the blue costume I'm guessing
that you probably read the new 52 run it
just saw that really hardcore Barry
Allen it does look really cool in Barry
Allen is slowly filling himself and
Wally with Speed Force so we might get
white lightning Barry and White
Lightning Wally pretty soon but if
you're ever frustrated by the TV show
just remember that they try to balance
things so that they can't get too
powerful otherwise there's no threats so
there's always some way if they get
really powerful for them to take it back
at the end of the day like Barry got
super powerful with the tachyons then
the surprise twist is a zoom did
something that Barry couldn't prevent
using his speed so he ended up having to
give it to him going back to square one
so it'll be interesting to see how they
solve the problem of Savitt are without
making Barry or Wally overpowered going
into season 4 but don't forget I'm doing
special giveaways for the Super Bowl
trailers so I had links for that at the
end of this it's going to be great going
to be crazy this weekend there's even
some stranger things season 2 that's
supposed to drop tomorrow so I'll try to
do as many of those videos as I can
while you wait for that supposed to
here for the new Logan trailer and you
can click here for this week's flash
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five and I'll see you in the
next video